it wouldn't be cyberpunk without
cybernetics
enhancing your body in the cyberpunk
universe is both commonplace but also
incredibly dangerous a slippery slope
where if you deck yourself out too much
you risk losing your humanity but this
was of little concern to one cyborg that
didn't have much humanity back when they
were human
and that's who we're talking about today
the legendary adam smasher
aka the guy who killed johnny silverhand
when it comes to these cyberpunk lore
videos we try and talk about characters
and history
we think might be relevant to the
upcoming video game
adam smasher is no exception and he'll
be making an appearance in 2077
right there so let's take a look at the
brief
but important history of adam smasher
adam real name unknown started out as a
typical street punk
in new york city growing up in the south
bronx adam was the leader
of his neighborhood gang the blood boys
even back then he had a nasty sadistic
streak with a dismissive attitude
towards human life
this would serve him well when he later
joined up with the army
although the army didn't see it the same
way discharging him for
quote bad conduct and insubordination
adam would return to the big apple as a
gun for hire
or street samurai as he likes to call it
this line of work suited him
until around 2015 when one day a
job went south and adam was hit by
several rpga
warheads turning him into a bag of meat
that is not a metaphor his friends
literally shoved the chunky remains of
his body
into a backpack and dragged him back to
new york
and yet adam was not fully dead
a mysterious corporation put him on life
support as a pile of flesh
only able to communicate through a tech
interface
they gave him an offer he could be saved
fully converted into a metal body
in exchange for 15 years of service to
them
adam accepted edwan's reborn as the
combat cyborg
adam smasher this mysterious employer
turned out to be
none other than the arasaka corporation
adam smasher became one of their prized
killers while still given the freedom to
work freelance
he would take on any job so long as it
fulfilled one condition
it needed to involve collateral damage
and civilian casualties
adam has long been obsessed with the
idea of being the strongest and
considered himself superior with his
metal body
adopting the mantra metal is better than
meat
his need to prove his way of life led to
a rivalry with the famous solo
morgan blackhand morgan was the opposite
of adam in almost every way
a professional that handled delicate
situations with grace
taking his targets in alive if possible
if adam could beat morgan he could prove
that metal was in fact better than meat
however
every time adam challenged him morgan
would ignore it
eventually the fourth corporate war
kicked off a bloody conflict between
arasaka and militech adam was called in
working the front lines for arasaka all
the while waiting for his chance to take
on morgan
who just so happened to be working for
militech he finally got his wish during
the infamous attack on the night city
arasaka tower
the details of this event are vague a
mystery to the general public of the
cyberpunk universe
and books like cyberpunk red state that
no one really knows what went down
however the adventure book shock wave
not only details what happened
but lets players participate in the
event what i'm about to talk about
is canonically supposed to have happened
but it's worth keeping in mind that
cyberpunk 2077
might change some of the details looking
to end the war
militech sent several strike teams into
arasaka tower
one led by morgan and another led by
rocker boy
johnny silverhand johnny's team was
tasked with breaking into the soulkiller
lab
which housed a dangerous program that
trapped people's minds in a digital
prison
leaving their body an empty shell the
plan went well
but johnny's team took a little too long
and on their way out
they were confronted by adam smasher and
a group of arasaka soldiers
pinned down in a cramped hallway by
gunfire things were not looking good
knowing their situation was hopeless
johnny smg in hand
tried to buy his team some time by
taking on adam smasher
but against adam's metal shell there
really wasn't much johnny could do
adam pulled out his auto shotgun and
tore johnny's body
into pieces in a matter of mere seconds
the body of the legendary rocker boy hit
the ground
johnny was dead this sacrifice gave
johnny's team
the chance to escape meanwhile morgan
blackhand's team had set up a nuclear
device
inside the building and then began
extraction on the rooftop
but of course it wasn't going to be that
simple adam smasher appeared holding the
mangled remains of one of morgan's
friends while taunting him
over the death of johnny morgan couldn't
ignore adam this time and stayed behind
so the rest of his team could escape
there on the rooftop of arasaka tower
adam smasher finally got his duel
with morgan blackhand a chance to see if
metal
was better than meat morgan's team
watched the battle from the sky
the two were still fighting each other
even as the nuclear detonation destroyed
the tower
under their feet both rivals fell into
the chaos below
their fate left unknown but as we now
know
adam smasher did in fact survive we
don't know much about what he's been up
to in the last 50 years but he still
works for arasaka
and has made night city his home which
brings us to cyberpunk 2077
though it hasn't been confirmed i think
it's safe to say he's not going to be an
ally to protagonist v
in fact with v on the run from arasaka
after stealing their prototype chip
i'm hoping adam's role is not unlike a
cyborg version of
resident evil's nemesis a metal
monstrosity
constantly hunting v down v also has the
digital ghost of
johnny silverhand in their head who i'm
sure will want some payback for their
untimely death
perhaps we'll finally get our answer if
metal is better than meat
thank you so much for watching this
episode in our cyberpunk lore series
if you're new i highly recommend you
check out the rest of our videos
such as the one on johnny silverhand and
the fourth corporate war
both of which provide more information
on the events of the destruction of
arasaka tower
we have a new video up every saturday
leading up to cyberpunk 2077's release
so we'll see you next week
you